hello everyone and welcome to a most
impressive game from round one uh of the
gold money asian rapid preliminaries
it's the seventh event of the 1.6
million dollars champions chess we're
the meltwater champions chester and
we have a game between alireza ferruga
and magnus carlsen
so the game has a lot of twists it has a
very exciting opening
uh it has it all so let's check it out
and we're gonna discuss what's happening
in the tournament
uh at some later rounds but uh as you
all know this uh
tournament um i wealth uh basically uh
is the return of ho yi fanta chess she's
been away from uh from the chess world
for
for for some time uh but now she
returned and we're very excited to see
how she will do so we will cover
some of her games with great pleasure so
let's check it out alireza with the
white pieces
opens with e4 we have e5 by magnus and
now
knight to c3 this is the vienna game and
is something that alireza
often employs in these top tier
tournaments it's basically
playing the king's gambit but with a uh
with a you know
sort of a safer kings gambit but it
offers a very very exciting play
especially if black also wants to play
a little bit aggressive so here magnus
goes knight to f6
bishop to c4 and now bishop to c5 you
could go for this knight captures an e4
uh but it's it's basically just um you
know quick way to
uh to equalize which is not something
that magnus is
interested in because okay you know if
you capture with with the knight
then we can play d5 but of course white
will play queen to h5 now threat and
checkmate
and then we're gonna see a nice knight
to d6 defending f7 attacking the bishop
here and now
you win back your pawn so queen captures
we can trade the queens captures
captures
and then bishop goes back to b3 and
black has this weird knight on d6 you're
gonna have to waste the tempo to get it
uh
away from there then then you can push
your pawn and continue the game but it's
nothing uh
magnus would be interested in playing in
such a well such a top tier event
so here bishop to c5 and now d3
uh we have d6 both players just playing
normal moves and
f4 now here here we have it almost the
king's gambit
we have knight to c6 knight to f3 and
now a6 by magnus
we have b3 not allowing this to come
with tempo then you can even play this
attack the knight and then you know the
good things might happen for black so
bishop to b3
and now h6 and this h6 here is a new
move so already as a move seven we have
a completely new game
uh so let's see how alireza deals with
this we have queen to e2
now he wants to play bishop to e3 as
long as this bishop is here
white cannot castle so bishop to g4 by
magnus and now
f captures an e5 we have d captures on
e5
and now bishop to e3 countering black's
dark square bishop here
we have knight to d4 and now there's a
double attack on this knight and
there's an attack on the queen so the
queen has to move queen to f2
and now bishop captures an f3 g captures
in knight to h5 magnus now
uh ruins alireza's king side pawn
structure and now he's preparing to
bring the other knight to f4 and then
the two knights will be a most
impressive here so alire is a castle's
queen side and now
knight to f4 and that's just uh two too
many knights here in alireza's half of
the board so
uh magnus uh maybe uh uh alireza is um
maybe considering removing one of them
uh but for the moment
just kinked a b1 a nice profile acting
uh
move with the king uh so you don't have
to worry about any bishop captures on e3
in the future coming with
check so knight captures on b3 it's a
very strong light square bishop
and now while you can capture with the a
pawn uh alireza decides to take off as
many pieces
away from the board so bishop captures
on c5 knight captures queen captures
and now magnus plays queen to d6 and he
feels very happy
uh he was able to avoid all the
complications of the of the vienna game
he's now going to trade queens and he's
going to play a very pleasant end game
so already accepts we have queen
captures and e6 d
c captures on d6 and now d4
yeah of course you have you have to play
this you don't want this pawn stuck here
uh we have queen side castles now by
magnus and now
rook to d2 now this rook can come to d1
and you can put more pressure along the
d
file we have knight back to e6 now
magnus puts pressure on the d4 pawn
and knight to e2 alireza defends the d4
pawn one more time
uh we have rook h2 f8 now magnus
preparing to strike in the central with
with f5 and now d5 alireza closes the
center
but this gives magnus the opportunity to
to activate his pieces so knights the g5
now
attacking this pawn here we have rook to
d3 defending but now
knight the h3 now threatening knight to
f2 to pick up one of the rooks and
the situation on the clock is now
already three minutes uh and
magnus four minutes and 30 seconds on
the clock so uh
although magnus spent a bit more time in
the opening now he caught up and now
it's alireza who is actually down on
time so here we have
rook to c1 now this doesn't really do
anything
and f5 continue continuing with the plan
uh attacking white's strong center we
have c4
uh and now f captures an e4 we have f
captures on e4 this is
exposes um the attack from aleris rook
to
the knight on h3 but now rook to f2
magnus is very very happy to trade this
as now his rook is also very active
so here if you capture for example
captures captures you attack the e4 pawn
uh white would have to defend with
something like this and then just rook
f8 you're bringing the other rook to f2
and then it's going to be a problem
uh defending this if you allow such a
thing
so another thing you could do and this
is by far the best for all it is
it's not what happened in the game is c5
c5 is the move
you want to you want to play uh now
after d captures on c5
we're going to play rook captures on c5
with check and after the king moves and
now we trade knights but now it's a bit
different because now this rook can
defend the pawn
and you don't have to commit this rook
to the defense of your pawn now you can
bring this rook for example the c3
have your rooks nicely doubled here uh
anything is possible
uh but okay after carlson's rook to f2
we have knight to see
three by ali and now magnus just picks
up a pawn
and now the problem is uh magnus is up a
pawn alireza's position is a bit more
active due to the advanced pawn
structure here but if
if magnus can start pushing those king
side pawns it's going to be very very
difficult for
alireza to stop them so here c5
algorithm wants to open up lines as
quickly as possible and now knight to f4
not rushing with with any captures here
we have rook d to d1
uh and now comes king to b8 by magnus so
what do you play here now you don't have
to worry about
this uh rook uh uh you know eyeing your
king
for for or any longer
uh and the problem for alireza is that
he's down on to one minute on the clock
it's one minute for all it is at two
minutes for magnus
uh and here we have c6 this is the most
active move and
it's the one alireza plays we rook to c8
and now comes knight to a4 and here
uh it's a very interesting position and
here the position requires a most
precise move
and well as they're both very low on
time i'm just going to show it to you
but here a move that's the most
impressive is king to c7
king to c7 again going in front of the
rook and stopping this knight to b6 idea
and here if for example c captures on b7
now you're just going to play king
captures on b7 and again there's no
knight to b6 and if cactus captures
then you're very happy here you don't
have to worry about anything here and
you can just start pushing your king
side pawns
and on the other hand after king to c7
if we see something like rook to c3 with
the idea of doubling up well then b5
traps the knight and
i mean it's uh the point is we want to
keep the
knight away from the b6 square but
magnus here and here magnus spent one
minute and 21 second
uh on his next move he played rook to e2
he went for the e4 pawn
uh but alireza seems to be ready for
this as he immediately played knight
to b6 so king to c7 kind of was needed
here to stop this knife from
infiltrating we have rook to c7 by
magnus now
knight to d7 with check uh king to a7
and now
rook to c4 now alireza wants to start
pushing these pawns here open up the
the position and maybe even checkmate
carlson's king because now
with the position being as it is the
knight covers uh b6 and b8 and if
the a file opens up this could be
checkmate so yeah let's see if he can do
it
magnus says nope that's way too way off
i'm just going to start pushing my past
pawn
yeah because that's how games are won we
rook the g1 by alireza going after this
pawn and now
magnus has a clear win so feel free to
pause the video and
win this game for magnus while i give
you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations i'm completely
ignoring this pawn
and doing what you do best and that's
pushing the pawn so congratulations to
everyone who found h4 as this
is now just winning now h3 is guarded by
the knight h2 is governed
guarded by the rook and there will be no
defense against this pawn a point is
that you do not want to defend the pawn
after the pawn is captured we're gonna
play h3
rook h7 we're gonna play h2 and now
we're threatening rookie one chuck king
here and then we're gonna bring a queen
into the game as our rook covers the h1
square
so white would have to defend with rook
to c1 but now we play rook to g2
now again what do you play here uh there
is not much for
for white to play whatever white plays
we're just going to play knight d3 now
attack the rook there's also a double
attack on the b2 pawn
and it's just a completely winning
position for black
if rook c3 we can even play knight f2
now we can just uh you know
we we cover the h1 square we also attack
this pawn so this rook has to go back
we're gonna start picking up the other
pawns now we create another pass pawn
and it's just
an unplayable position for white so
after rook to g1 alvarez was able to
uh well sort of uh convince magnus into
seeing ghosts and magnus played
g6 he defended uh his pawn but that's
one uh
valuable tempo that he gave gave away so
alireza starts pushing on the queen side
he plays
a4 and now magnus plays h4 now he wants
to play h3h2 but alireza gets b4
in and now slowly but surely we are
getting that
what what we discussed uh so here we
have b6 by magnus
and now comes b5 we have a5 magnus of
course not interested in opening up the
position
and now it seems that the position is
completely closed and
magnus can just continue winning the
position by pushing his pass pawn
uh but alireza says nope and he plays
the knight captures on e5
uh so what do you play here or the
knight cannot be captured
if this spawns if these two pawns start
marching forward then it's just game
over
uh you can easily just win the game
there's not not much black can do to
stop this
so after knight captures on e5 magnus
just continues pushing we have
h3 and now rook to h1
and now magnus uh happily gives uh
gives the piece back knight captures on
d5 he says nope
you take my piece and alireza could
definitely grab this if captures then
rook captures then he can capture on h3
the material is equal aleris's position
is better
probably magnus would be able to defend
but it's hard to say they are both very
long on time
anything could happen so instead after
knight captures on d5 with knight
captures on g6 by ali
and now knight to e3 and now what do you
play here
uh alireza says all right my rook is
under attack rook to c3 now if the
knight moves so we can always pick up
the h3 pawn
so knights the g4 by magnus and now
comes
knight to f4 so what do you play here
the rook is under attack the pawn is
under attack
uh what what do you play well uh here
magnus picks up the e4 pawn
now attacks the knight here and now you
can finally eliminate
uh this pass pawn but is this the best
the best thing to do
uh it's hard to say uh feel free to
pause the video here and now win the
game for alireza
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
not listening to my suggestion and
grabbing the h3 pawn
and for those of you who decided to go
to d5 then congratulations
you are a you are a a most excellent
player
uh so here at knights to d5 this is what
all it is a played and
that's a huge problem for magnus because
the rook is under attack and you can't
move the rook if you move the rook then
we get rook captures on h3 and how do
you defend against this
there's simply no no defending this all
right it's just uh
uh too too uh terrible of a position for
example 95 you can try and bring some
defenders into the game just check and
after the king moves we're going to
bring the knight here with
check and then king b8 and then rook the
b7 will be checkmate so
that that's a huge problem so after 95
magnus played knights to f2 he said all
right now i'm going to attack your rook
but alireza just captured on c7
magnus captured on h1 and here we have
rook captures on h3
and it was in this position that magnus
carlsen resigned to the game on move 45
as there is nothing more to be done here
problem is that the knight is under
attack and it doesn't matter whether you
uh the defended or you move the knight
the plan is uh the plan is the same
after the night moves for example knight
f2 we're going to play rook to h8
and now you see that all of these
squares are covered
we we reach the position from the
thumbnail and there is no defending
against rook to a8
checkmate so magnus of course saw this
and after rook to h3
he resigned in the game so he defended
well against the vienna game but
incredible as it is uh alireza once
again brings the vienna
uh to a top tier tournament challenges
the world champion in all time formats
to a vienna game and
wins the game so that's that's how you
play good chess so congratulations to
alireza and
i hope you guys enjoyed this game it was
a really really wild one
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank
jorge campos david traynor
kevin stormeyer paige myers and the
ching yi-chan for a contribution to my
channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
very nice tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day